zwar ist luca und herzlich willkommen
wir heute meine lieben freunde endlich
wieder zueinander der wiso der whatsapp
fällt mit luca
ich laufe über die straße und gäbe einem
entgegenkommenden fahrradfahrer high
five wo ist das problem das war nicht
mein kumpel und er hatte die hand nur
ausgestreckt um anzuzeigen dass er
abbiegt
ja und damit herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen episode dummheit mit luca
ruf mal zurück habe gerade zwei mal mit
deiner hose und dir dass du mir person
anrufs und ihr hört so richtig dieses
ganze branche und man hört irgendwie so
leicht bestimmen im hintergrund man
denkt einfach hat jetzt gerade seine
hosentasche irgendwie das gespräch
angenommen immer wenn mir langweilig ist
seele ich meine arme
ja
ich habe übrigens mein video hintergrund
da hinten ein wenig verändert aufgrund
der aktuellen situation
aber um zurück zu den bauabfällen hierzu
kommen die zählt man in seine arme macht
er dann 12 bei gutem wetter können wir
auch eine radtour machen hast du denn
funktionieren das fahrrad natürlich das
ist das einzige was in meinem leben
wirklich funktioniert völlig fühle ich
sehr stark den whatsapp fällt die sache
ist allerdings ich selbst bin als so
doll in die pedale getreten wenn man
einfach dass mein fahrrad einfach in der
mitte durchgebrochen ist und habe ich
auch hier schon etwas vorbereitet das
ist nämlich in meinem buch vielleicht
haben das ja einige von euch zuhause
hallo mein name ist lukas haben eine
mutter nicht mal mein leben geschrieben
und da sieht man dass das ist
durchgebrochen
[Musik]
wie das aussieht
na ja gut ich war er habe ja früher die
tour de france gewonnen 1834 die fresse
du raten die nacht hinterlässt weiterhin
merklich ihre spuren eifrig versucht mit
dem führerschein an der tanke zu
bezahlen wirkte anscheinend sehr solide
dabei erkennt es nicht wenn man mit
seinem führerschein bezahlen will von
dem restalkohol in meinem körper würde
ich im nüchternen zustand noch mal
betrogen werden das kenne ich von sandra
solcher nachrichten mir schreibt eine
person um 22 31 stecken schon wieder
fest also vielleicht im aufzug oder
keine ahnung was allerdings genau in der
minute schreibt er da auch wieder ach
nein doch nicht
dann allerdings dreieinhalb stunden
später stecken schon wieder fest
ja
tipp für euch und zwar willig an eurer
stelle nicht mehr feststecken summarum
liegt aber im endeffekt niemann bei
welcher fahrschüler hast du dich nun
angemeldet baez oder bbs du wolltest
doch bei b machen warum auf einmal
anders entschieden habe bei b
den eingang nicht gefunden ja sowas
kenne ich auch nur vom sandra ok was
machst du ich mache mir sorgen schreibt
eine person um halb drei nachts und die
andere person antwortet ich genieße den
boden
er gibt nichts besseres als ein halb
drei nachts stockbesoffen einfach den
boden zu genießen macht und was ich dir
noch sagen wollte du hast voll die
schöne hautfarbe bison trost alles klar
formal richtig nettes tolles kompliment
hier schreibt eine person um 4 uhr 27
nachts liegt gerade in so einem gang und
zwei stunden später um 6 uhr 26 schreibt
sie jetzt immer noch
ok ich gebe es zu all odds fällt sollte
ja wieso da kommen eigentlich von sandra
hat sollte eigentlich eine überraschung
wir hatten ich stehe vor deiner haustür
du bist aber nicht da und handys aus wo
steckst du freue mich riesig auf dich
kommen ganz schnell du fehlst mir so
kues du bist wo verdammt bin auf der
autobahn kurz war karlsruhe wollte
überraschungsbesuch bei dir und ich
drehe mich binnen vier stunden da das
gibt's doch nicht ach du sch was gerade
nicht ob ich lachen oder heute soll es
irgendwie lustig aber irgendwie sei es
auch extrem traurig ich habe eine
minibar in deinem zimmer oder in deiner
leber ja das ist auch wieder ein schatz
war noch von sandro mir hier wird sogar
singstar gespielt kommen her hat das
kriege ich nicht okay das schaffst du
nicht mehr ja sandra bin da kannst du
öfter drücken welche wohnung kommen
einfach hoch meine tür ist offen wo
bleibst du na dann nicht als vorschuss
bekommen tür im ersten stock war offen
bin dort am frühstücken
warum lassen sich eigentlich immer alter
deine sms gibt keinen sinn du bist voll
wie ein eimer kann das sein dogs der
sinne ist gut versteckt und außerdem
einen aux leer sein also max deines sns
kein sieben ja ich bin da voll und ganz
deiner meinung wollen wir bratäpfel
machen oder mit marzipan mit marzipan
habe ich sie noch nie gemacht aber gerne
wie hast du mir dann immer gemacht mit
meiner oma
ich finde es gibt nichts schlimmeres
als leute die so dumm sind irgendwie
dass die nachrichten falsch verstehen
oder ironie nicht verstehen oder keine
ahnung was ich glaube jeder kennt das
wenn man mit irgendeiner person schreibt
irgendwie den ironischen witz macht oder
sich irgendwie lustig machte da keine
ahnung was die anderen person dass
irgendwie total ernst nimmt oder auch
hier so einfache fragen oder aussagen
nicht verstehen ich finde es gibt nichts
schlimmeres habe mir heute einen 3ds xl
in rosa gekauft und musste meinen
ausweis vorlegen weil der betrag den
taschengeld paragrafen übersteigt und
das mit 22 bitter würde mir zu denken
geben also klar denn hier ist es so ich
bin jetzt gerade 24 geworden also ich
gehe seit sechs jahren nicht mehr zur
schule und wohl auch seit sechs jahren
nicht mehr zu hause aber bekommt ihr
noch taschengeld
also ich bin halt überhaupt nicht so am
laufe der zeit was gerade so kinder sage
ich mal im alter von weiß nicht wann
bekommt man taschengeld zwischen 10 und
vielleicht und wenn ihr taschengeld
bekommt wie viel bekommt hier oben ist
ein umfrage also stimmt dort gern mal ab
mich würde es echt mal interessieren ich
weiß gar nicht mehr wie viel ich
bekommen habe auf jeden fall sei wenig
je weniger man bekommt desto besser kann
man halt auch mit geld umgehen finde ich
es ist alles irgendwie vor und nach
wieder fit wie geht's liegt im bett und
lese die sms mit einem auge das andere
schläft noch das kenn ich an alle unter
euch die schon mal so richtig feiern
waren und richtig wenig gepennt haben
dann völlig verkatert am nächsten morgen
aufgewacht sind man ist immer so
tageslicht ist
mal nach halb stück schlafe bin im 5 min
wieder bei euch
da wir kennst du nicht wenn man sich
eine halbe stunde schlafen legt aber
dann in fünf minuten wieder bei seinen
freunden ist hier schreibt eine person
die nachricht wie war dein tag baby ich
habe den ganzen tag an dich gedacht an
claudia julia nicole tribüne und vanessa
gibt es solche leute wirklich alters ist
abnormal ekelhaft hier und kreis eine
person das wort kürzen bei seinen
whatsapp vorgaben und schreibt das wort
habe ich ewig nicht benutzt wie so
schlägt mir dieses dumme what's up das
land vor ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist
das ein zeichen ein zeichen dass es bald
passieren wird nedas mich whatsapp sogar
vernaschen will ja whatsapp will dich
vernaschen alles klar
was bin ich für ein versprachen lernen
lukrative indikatoren yoshikawa wie man
korrekt am ende ein kompletter idiot
lust etwas zu machen was wofür ich mich
rasieren müsste würde ich jetzt mal
nicht ausschließen dann ein
der korb hat wehgetan hier schreibt eine
person mit seinem opa und so fragt die
person hannover wie geht's dir und der
opa antwortet mir geht's gut und die
drei ihre kommst du noch nicht mit dem
neuen handy gleichzeitig mal am
wochenende wie man damit umgeht doch
alles gut war gestern nur so hacke voll
da konnte ich nicht mehr tippen
das ist sein opa wie man sich einfach
wünscht das ist ich weiß nicht wie es
bei euch jungen wie damals auch so bei
familientreffen war aber wird bei euch
auch immer kratz getrunken
also egal ob ihr jetzt irgendwie alkohol
trinkt oder nicht oder ist noch nicht
dürft oder ist allgemein nicht macht
kriegt ihr mit dass die anderen sich mal
so richtig abschnittsweise
familientreffen bei uns war das nie der
fall
und ich hatte richtig gern mal meine
großeltern damals als sie noch gelebt
haben einfach richtig betrunken erlebt
es ist keine ahnung das hätte ich
irgendwie so witzig gefunden sich dann
mit denen sogar gott und die welt zu
unterhalten ich habe vorhin kerl
kennengelernt er bat mich diese nummer
zu wählen weil er kein netz hatte sein
name war tobias stuttgart könntest du
mir seine handynummer schreiben bitte
wir haben uns dann verabschiedet und ich
habe seine nummer nicht wäre wirklich
verliebt war mir sehr sympathisch danke
grüße tanja nö alles klar das war noch
krasser corp hat sehen wir gerade hatten
wir nun allerdings auch schon zum
letzten wort fällt für die heutige
episode uns vorschreibt eine person das
hier sag mal wie alt ist eigentlich
deine kleine schwester endlich mal daran
alter ich schwöre ich töte dich auch
wenn du auch nur daran denkt so weit wie
langsam haben es auch mal weg damit ist
sie trotzdem noch kein tüten und auf
keinen fall werde ich zu lassen dass
einer wie du mit ihr was auch immer
jetzt klein und unschuldig und süß und
wird daran nichts ändern und auch sonst
keiner dafür werde ich sorgen die
nächsten tagen die 100 jahre denke ich
mal dran ich meine das ernst h
mir ging es nur darum sie knutscht
gerade mit deiner freundin okay
okay das war eine krasse wendung der
ereignisse an der stelle habe ich das
heute wieder ist allerdings offen meine
lieben freunde wenn euch diese
mittlerweile schon achte episode potsdam
fans auch so gut gefallen hat wie mir oh
mein gott ich klinge gerade wie so ein
richtiger tv-moderator dass auf jeden
fall gern einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da wenn ihr wollt dass auch
nächstes wochenende eine neue updates
folge kommt dann schon teil 9
mein gott das wird eine richtige serie
auf einem kanal naja wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal dann abonniert
gern einen kanal denn ich sehe das hier
in meinen analytics statistiken also
dass viele die meine video schon gar
nicht abonnent sind
[Musik]